I'm Ted Hopson I'm the chef/owner of the
devel whether we're gonna make food that
I eat on my days off instead of food
that I make at the restaurant every day
we're gonna go here at grassroots buy
some fun ingredients I grew up very
Italian my family is all Italian so
we're gonna make some pasta that's it's
what we we're gonna do a style called
ragu Genovese a like a very braised meat
a heavy kind of ragu first ingredient
were gonna get wine the most important
ingredient if we go with the Pinot Noir
we'll have to have a sweeter style
probably buy two bottles one to drink
and one to cook with the kind of denser
your sauce the thicker your pasta should
be in the light of your sauce the
lighter your pasta should be we're gonna
have a meaty sauce so we really want
them with more texture Tomatoes that'll
be perfect
bone broth it's a fancy way of saying
stock really I think the chef's when
they're at home don't want complicated
things like we always usually just want
to make it easy so that's what this is
it's a very easy like raised me pasta we
don't serve this dish in my restaurant
and this is like that family heirloom
dish so we're back at my house now and
we're gonna go take our groceries make
some dinner I always like to use dutch
ovens they'll last like lifetime these
are the things that people like pass
down to their kids so I'm just gonna cut
it in half salt and pepper
people always ask I call has a chef do
you have like lobster and truffles and
steak at home it's like no not at all
your day off it's no different in a chef
stay off it you don't exactly look
forward to like hours of work
give it a nice sizzle when you put it in
the pan and you can see you're starting
to get that nice call it old Italian
cuisine and culture isn't rooted in the
fact that it's expensive it's rooted in
the fact that it's made you know for
people on a budget and so you use a lot
of onion because it really adds that
bulb or the sauce that's not already
there this sauce takes a long time to
make there's no if ands or buts about it
so we're gonna take our time they're
gonna do it
so I grew up around food my grandmother
like I said being an immigrant Italian
like all she did was you know cook and
clean every day hey let's check our be
browning kind of adds flavor adds
dimension as body that's gonna come out
so now we're gonna get our onions that's
gonna go right in
so onions are sweated down now I'm gonna
take a bowl of wine cut it in very
relaxing should be a relaxing thing you
know if you're cooking at home and
you're stressing out you're doing it
wrong
we're gonna take our Tomatoes we're just
gonna add the braised meat back in raise
is cooking a meat kind of below a simmer
for a long period of time in a liquid
cover it i shredded the meat I had a
back into that liquid I reduced until
it's nice and thick you're looking for a
pasta sauce in the
yeah you want to use a good amount of
salt whenever you're making pasta that
will help season the pasta itself so
instead of it just being bland it'll
actually have a little bit of flavor
Gouda is very like melty we're gonna use
the water we live we got the store what
makes food magical is that someone loved
it at some point someone really took
care and attention into it and I think
there's that emotional component to
cooking that sometimes people overlook
that I feel is very important like I was
saying earlier this is a dish that my
grandmother used to make for me this is
what the day offs are all about is you
know being able to spend this time this
is the fun part about a chef day off